et là
la deuxième photo comme celle-ci datait de quatre mois
sans cette angoisse dans ta poitrine,
qu'elle veut travailler et qu'elle n'a pas le
que faire, asseyez-vous et attendez, mettez-le dans votre main
de Dieu maintenant que nous sommes de retour
le travail est que ce système donne de l'action et
il y a un grand bonheur quand
J'ai éteint le bleu du cercle que les gens ont rempli
de fierté et
et là
m'aider à l'intérieur était la meilleure chose
parce qu'il n'a nulle part où emmener l'enfant
Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait un endroit où mettre l'enfant
c'est sortir, mon enfant, pourquoi rester enfermé
à l'intérieur de la maison, c'est vrai, donc c'est un super
J'ai vraiment aimé l'idée et
le terrain location tour eau lumière
les coûts pour les artistes sont donc
trop fort alors le lecteur non non
peut tout fournir, non ?
les besoins du cirque et
et là